all right welcome back everybody it's
the easiest illegal border crossing
along the rio grande river around the
rio grande
that according to our next guest the
texas sheriff who claims his small town
is being overrun by migrants who wait
for the river to reach
its lowest point so they can wait across
in just minutes
val verde county texas sheriff joe frank
martinez joins us now good morning to
you sheriff
good morning how are you all doing we're
doing great thank you thank you for what
you're doing i know you all are working
so hard down there what are you seeing
tell us some of the stories
well we're seeing a large number of
individuals coming across from the
countries of honduras guatemala
nicaragua
cuba haiti valenzuela this
this month alone uh we've held
for our border patrol partners 538
individuals from those
from those countries so there's just
a wave of people coming through yeah how
do you hold them
well we just wait on the side of the
river uh one crossing point
uh here in brotherhood of the county
that all these individuals are coming
through
uh we hold them there for border patrol
to arrive they transport
them to get them processed once they're
processed they're turned over to an ngo
and the ngo ships them out of ships in
marami county
they do and the problem is
for your county there are costs
associated with them when they're there
aside from the the exposure to covid
which obviously is happening according
to the infection rates
but who's is the federal government
helping
your county with offsetting the costs or
are you guys just on your own we're
basically on our own
uh just the other day 75
of my uh workforce for that shift
was occupied assisting border patrol so
you know when i have four deputies
working and three of them are tied up
for the majority part of the day
you know that just we can't serve our
citizens in our community the way we
need to be serving them yeah
is it true you're seeing them arrive
with cell phones and luggage
and clothes new clothes yes they're
they're coming across with cell phones
uh they've
some got credit cards new clothes
they abandoned a new set of clothes on
the river because they're wet and they
get into
a brand new set of clothes uh prior to
border patrol picking them up
yeah i just uh laugh when the president
united states says this is cyclical
what's happening before i got here
you say no it wasn't the bind
administration wiped out the old policy
under president trump uh when they took
over they didn't have a plan to go
into place and he went on to say when
they get here you ask them why they got
here they said because
this guy's more lenient yes and that's
i mean that's uh straight across the
board you ask them that this is their
opportunity to come across
system they indicated 783
in this three months alone you know
they've got 881 of those uh same type of
reports so that's half
that's almost half the work that they
did that they did last year
uh done in three months sure of this
year sheriff
the white house says that a vast
majority of these migrants are being
turned around and sent right back to
mexico
number one if you would answer whether
or not you think that's true and
secondly tell us about the people of
your
county and your community are they happy
about this are they okay with it or
are they surprised that it's happening
in such vast numbers
so the answer is they're not all being
sent back the only ones that are really
being sent back are the mexican
uh the people from the countries i
mentioned they're all being processed
and sent
on to wherever their destination is
going to go
now the citizens in my community they're
concerned
uh they're they're afraid i had a
meeting with them
uh almost two weeks ago on
near the location where all these
immigrants are coming across
and they're concerned they want to know
what is their right to defend themselves
and stuff
so you know i just try to try to
ease their calm because a lot of these
people they're basically
family units and they've been peaceful
to this point
all right to this point wow right
exactly
sheriff thank you so much for being here
and what you do
thank you for having me good luck